plus de quarante et un mille kilos de
nourriture sont jetées chaque seconde
dans le monde
au canada c'est près de 60 % de la
nourriture produite au pays qui est jeté
comment on décide que ce qui est comique
est-ce que légiférer nous donnerait des
meilleurs résultats jandaud on est
totalement déconnectée de la production
des aliments jetés des fruits en valais
dans un emballage plastique dans le
cruel cci sont loin de logique à la
saccharine
zachary simard c'est lui qui a publié
cette photo sur les réseaux sociaux qui
a provoqué beaucoup de réactions du
point de rencontre et moi manger des
fruits ou peu emballé dans les auberges
en plastique des choses encore bonnes à
manger dans ton guerrier qui moisit là
d'un étudiant en biologie il travaille
dans une épicerie
il trouve choquant de devoir jeter les
aliments est vendu je trouve que c'est
une logique de jeter des aliments comme
cela la poubelle à la l'immédiat le
compost le recyclage selon rené audet de
la chaire de recherche sur la transition
écologique le gaspillage alimentaire est
souvent considéré comme une perte
économique ont traduit le gaspillage
alimentaire en termes économiques et de
cette façon là on le rend un peu normal
c'est à dire que on parle plutôt de
pertes
les commerçants nous dit c'est normal on
a trois ou quatre pour cent de perte
dans ce parc urbain
nous rencontrons marlene de sean
consultante en environnement dans une
épicerie sait pas toujours la même
personne qui va porter les matières dans
les conteneurs donc c'est sûr que chaque
personne va emporter une petite quantité
plus une petite puce une petite on s'en
rend pas compte mais c'est quand on va
ouvrir le corner est que tout le monde
est passé c'est là qu'on voit la grande
quantité et c'est là qu'on doit regarder
qui se retrouvent justement danser et
comment on pourrait mettre en place des
mesures pour pour que salah et leur prix
voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à la
litterna ce qu'assure meilleur système
d'inventaire du meilleur
attention je vous amener dans une ruelle
d'ailleurs une épicerie dans ce
conteneur à compost
nous trouvons plusieurs aliments encore
comestibles une femme des raisins je
pense qu'on peut récupérer d'autres
villes et eu des réserves encore ces
unions
lorsqu'on peut partir avec top 20 cette
abondance cette espèce de perfection de
la lima la réalité c'est que je pense
que cette vision fait partie du problème
ce gaspillage alimentaire ailleurs au
centre ville une journée de pluie un
autre conteneurs remplis d'aliments ont
montré ces images à pierre alexandre
blouin de l'association des détaillants
en alimentation
en fait je connais pas la raison pour
laquelle ces produits là se retrouvent
dans la benne à déchets ce soir est
premièrement être mis dans le combat
probablement que certains systèmes leur
ait pu être gérée différemment si ça
semble aussi l'enfouissement
c'est certain que c'est la matière
qu'ils voyent gaspillé totalement qui va
émettre du méthane un site
d'enfouissement donc on n'est pas plus
avancé
au canada les aliments jetés produisent
plus de 22 millions de tonnes de gaz
carbonique
ce qui contribue au changement
climatique il ya plusieurs années au
complet pour contrôler on pense à la
température option prévoyant une belle
fin de semaine avec beaucoup de gens qui
vont vouloir faire du barbecue
on va augmenter les stocks de boucherie
finalement il pleut toute la fin de
semaine
ces produits leur ont pas été vendus
c'est malheureux mais nous on doit
toujours jongler avec nos attentes
versus les ventes 30 % de tout ce qu'on
produit mondialement est gaspillée ben
c'est 30 % de terres en troll 30%
d'autres ou utiliser 30 % de ressources
très importantes transports donc ça va
au delà de tout ça alors je pense oui
l'épicier son rôle à jouer en multi
coeurs mais le consommateur aussi un
rôle à jouer en achetant la quantité
jusqu'à besoins en s'assurant aussi que
ce qui va acheter
même si c'est un peu pas qui c'est pas
grave comment on décide que ce qui est
comestible
comment on peut décider si un aliment
est encore comestibles très subjectif en
effet dans les étalages
une première sélection est faite par
l'économie puis une deuxième par les
consommateurs les imparfaits sont
rejetés ils vont renforcer ce mécanisme
de sélection que les communes mettent
déjà en place et vont eux-mêmes taponner
comment facile à manipuler les fruits
légumes et saab a introduit des
bactéries au fur et à mesure il ya des
choses qui sortent il ya des choses qui
sont discriminés et ont une vision la
fraîcheur est à la fois produite par le
marketing faire les attentes des
consommateurs
personne n'en prends la responsabilité
puis en bout de ligne ça génère du
gaspillage
la date de péremption aussi génère du
toutes ces voix de café sont rejetés
alors qu'il reste encore six semaines
avant d'atteindre la date de péremption
le café est ici récupéré par moisson
montréal tout comme ses laitues romaine
voilà y est encore très bon endroit
quand il reste deux jours trois jours ou
encore sous cette lettre il a énormément
dias qui est une part et d'autre part on
a 150 mille personnes à montréal
seulement qui peine à manger trois repas
par jour il s'est juste de mettre
ensemble c'est juste de se mobiliser
une mobilisation qui fonctionne avec 15
millions de kilos de nourriture
récupérer et redonner des dons
proviennent de distributeurs producteurs
grossistes et 8 % des dons proviennent
des épiceries ont une capacité
organisationnelle si là on est capable a
changé beaucoup plus aux organismes nous
disent qu'on répond environ 60% de leurs
besoins et qui encore de la place pour
aller rechercher 4,5 mio kg plus
aujourd'hui des bacs de laitue des
oranges du pain et toute cette viande
c'est quoi ça un gigot d'agneau 80
dollars si vous l'avez pas récupérer
cette pièce de viande le elle se serait
trouvé à fait semblable au soleil à la
46 jours sawyer un million de kilos de
viande sauver du gaspillage alimentaire
mais on pourrait faire plus en france
par exemple des lois obligent les
épiciers a redonné les invendus et nous
on est des détaillants on est là pour
vendre des aliments on peut pas avoir un
système de distribution des aliments tu
le sais c'est pas notre nature de
commerce d'amasser des organismes qui
veulent collaborer avec nous suffit
d'approcher novembre décembre à l'enfant
présente d'abord décider qui est le
responsable du gaspillage c'est
contribuer à régler le problème est
qu'en réalité la responsabilité du
gaspillage à les partager tout ce qui
peut être fait pour réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire on devrait le
faire comme société commune
comme organisation devant l'ampleur que
ma publication en plus je pense que la
majorité des gens ça les touche
énormément
l'épicerie mort affirmé qu'ils allaient
installer un système de compostage et le
recyclage ainsi que fort à faire avec
une organisation pour donner d'enrique
sont bonnes à manger on sera peut-être
vu pour une vision du monde qui valorise
l'aliment comme autre chose que de
marchandises
je pense que ça c'est autant pour la
chaîne et l'industrie agroalimentaire
pour le consommateur depuis le début de
ce reportage
il c'est gaspiller dans le monde plus de
17 millions de kilos d'aliments
[Musique]